The best way,
the best way to teach people critical
thinking is to teach them to write,
and I made this little thing that I put
online.
It's,
I don't know if maybe it is it in the
psych for 34 website.
Did I post that rubric for Essay
Writing?
It is still on.
Is it not on for 34.
Is that not working
when you were doing?
Oh
yeah.
Oh,
okay.
Well there's an essay.
Whoa,
that's too bad.
It's not on the site for 34 website even
because I updated it anyways.
I have this guide to writing this.
If it isn't on the 4:34
website,
it is definitely on the [inaudible]
website and it steps people through the
process of writing because what's
happened now,
it's very hard to teach people to write
because it's unbelievably time intensive
and like writing marketing a good essay.
That's really easy.
Check a.
You did everything right,
right.
Marketing a bad essay.
Oh my God.
The words are wrong.
The phrases are wrong.
The sentence is wrong.
They're not ordered right in the
paragraphs.
The paragraphs aren't coherent and the
whole thing makes no sense,
so trying to tell the person what they
did wrong.
It's like,
Whoa,
you did everything wrong.
Everything about this essay is wrong.
Well,
that's not helpful either.
You have to find the few little things
they did half right and you have to
teach them what they did wrong.
It's really expensive and so what I did
with this rubric was trying to address
that from the production side instead of
the grading side,
but the best thing you can do is teach
people to write because there's no
difference between that and thinking and
one of the things that just blows me
away about universities is that no one
ever tell students why they should write
something.
It's like,
well,
you have to do this assignment.
Well,
why are you writing well?
You need the grade.
It's like,
no,
you need to learn to think because
thinking makes you act effectively in
the world.
Thinking makes you win the battles you
undertake and those could be battles for
good things.
If you can think and speak and write,
you are absolutely deadly.
Nothing can get in your way,
so that's why you learn to write.
It's like when I can't believe that
people aren't just told that it's,
it's,
it's like it's the most powerful weapon
you could possibly provide someone with
and I mean,
I know lots of people who've been
staggeringly successful and watched them
throughout my life.
I mean those people,
you don't want to have an argument with
them.
They'll just slash you into pieces and
not in a malevolent way.
It's like if you're gonna make your
point and they're going to make their
point.
You better have your points organized
because otherwise you are going to look
like and be an absolute idiot.
You are not going to get anywhere.
And if you can formulate your arguments
coherently and make a presentation,
if you can speak to people,
if you can lay out a proposal.
God,
people give you money,
they give you opportunities,
you have influence.
That's what you're at university for.
And so that's what you do is you know
your urine English,
right?
You're in your new languages anyway.
So it's like,
yeah,
teach,
teach people to be articulate because
that's the most dangerous thing you can
possibly be.
So,
and that's motivating.
If people know that,
it's like,
well,
why are you learning to write?
Because your,
here's your sword,
here's your m 16,
right?
Here's your bulletproof vest.
Like you learn how to use them,
but it's just,
it's an endless mystery to me why that
isn't made self evident.
So
that's the sort of thing that can drive
you mad.
Trying to sort out.
It's like people are,
there's a,
there's a conspiracy to bring people
into the education system to make them
weaker.
So
I guess that keeps the competition down.
Maybe that's one way of thinking about
it.
If your students are stupid,
they're not going to challenge you.